many fireworks displays are canceled
across the country tonight because as
you know the coronavirus still in full
force from the Hollywood Bowl to the
Boston Pops the celebrations that
attract thousands have all been called
off Macy's big 4th of July event in New
York City will be made-for-tv with
pop-up shows and secret locations the
Sousa family is behind the Macy's Show
and hundreds more they're considered
America's first family of fireworks
Carter Evans shows us how they will
still light up the sky for a massive
display at Mount Rushmore
that's where President Trump will be
watching from the Rockets red glare -
bombs bursting in air for more than a
century the souza family has been
creating magic in the sky
and on the cracked earth deep in the
California desert
we met Paul Souza at a pop-up test site
to prepare for 4th of July celebrations
this little cup here is the lift charge
or at least what's left of them after
coronavirus fears caused mass
cancellations
how many fireworks this place you
normally do every year roughly around
400 on the 4th of July about 2,000
throughout the year and how many this
year 50 it's pre bleak 3 2 1 fire the
susan's are the firing force behind some
of the world's biggest celebrations a
business they always consider to be
recession proof we're in the public
gathering business and public gatherings
are what's going on we're actually
standing here today doing a test and
it's gonna be the first time I've shot
fireworks in 3 months and I think we're
all just giddy like teenagers to do this
tonight in 3 2 1 fire the fireworks he's
auditioning tonight we'll end up
dazzling people at one of the most
important shows of his career and
Independence Day celebration at Mount
Rushmore National Monument with the
president in attendance there hasn't
been fireworks there in 10 years the
president's gonna be war presidents
gonna be there yeah some of these new
fireworks might be used in the Rushmore
show will be used as a special show we
better do good or we're gonna get
slammed
this simulation is part of pyro
spectaculars planning for the rushmore
show which will consist of more than
10,000 fireworks launching from seven
locations one atop George Washington's
head everything's got to get up that
mountain by manpower man and woman power
the National Park Service stopped
fireworks at the monument more than a
decade ago citing pollution concerns and
fire danger in January 2020 the
president responded I said you mean you
can't have fireworks because of the
environment
yeah environmental reasons I say what
can burn its stone you know it's stone
and the Park Service changed its - we
have to be precise
I don't want scorch marks on presidents
heads or no shells or fireworks bouncing
around and so it's it's sensitive after
collecting data in the desert the
process moves to the computer where
fireworks are timed to the music
it promises to be a spectacular show
but as big as it is it won't be enough
to support the company sixty-eight
percent of our business is on the 4th of
July one day a year and there's no real
reduce its even worse for other
fireworks companies 75% of their revenue
comes from this one day and it takes a
year of making and storing millions of
pounds of explosives the Souza's arsenal
of shells are stored in 14 underground
bunkers the American pyrotechnics
Association is now asking Congress for
additional funding to help these
businesses survive until next year pyro
spectacular CEO Jim Souza is already
feeling the pressure this is five
generations now and this is your
business and how much does that weigh on
you affects you all over emotionally
physically we'll have to have hope and
faith that it's going to get better
while the Souza's may face an uncertain
future their ultimate hope is to light
up America's skies for years to come
for CBS the sporting Carter Evans
Lucerne Valley California
[Music]
boy guys imagine the pressure that the
souza family must feel because you get
this one moment that everybody's waiting
for fireworks never get old and it's
always nice to see them on the fourth of
July in any form but something tells me
it's gonna be a-okay tonight these guys
are good they're good
ten thousand fireworks from seven
different locations launching from the
top of George Washington's head I'd be
down for that yeah I think it's gonna be
great I think everything okay but I will
be interested in watching the Sun come
up the next day and then see if we have
any sit marks on them it's curious just
be curious but it'll be a good time for
sure how to be careful all right wait
guys before we go could wait wait Vlad
but it's not fireworks but can I just
show you what we've done here
when Canton is done yes red white and
blue in our California location we are
very proud of this we worked on this a
long time so I do thank you Kenton cameo
come on Kent stepper